whoa and see that coming
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks it's been a while since I've
done a Doctor Who list about the closest
I've come for the past few months has
been things like ranking the episodes in
a series as I've been going through the
overdue dark troop but let's get back
into nice juicy lists of stuff I made
that sound actually really unappealing
moving on so I put this one as a vote to
the patreon supporters gave them a few
options they have opted that this is
gonna be a countdown of the top ten
twists of Doctor Who I did initially
consider including classic who into this
the thing is is that classic who didn't
do a ton of twist classic who did
cliffhangers a lot almost every episode
actually but they didn't do a ton of
really big twists and the ones that they
went for were usually confined to the
story that they were in and not you know
big massive upheavals the way that
modern era doctor who does so I'm gonna
stick to modern era for this I've got 10
these are all good in my estimation and
they were honestly difficult to order
but let's get going
number 10 the cult of Skaro reveal so
you really gotta roll your head back to
appreciate this twist because at the end
of series 1 of Doctor Who at the end of
the parting of the ways
the Daleks got wiped out dissolved into
atoms so far as we knew no Daleks were
left and then we come into the two-part
finale for series 2 and where we already
have the reveal of the Cybermen as
the ghosts so we have our big villain
for the finale but wait there's this
weird sphere this void ship thing what
is going on there and then it opens up
and out comes Daleks the cult of Skaro
and this was well before the overuse of
the Dalek tour they just coming and kept
coming back year after year after year
after year so having it here this was a
really good impact and it felt it felt
really rousing at the time that it
happened and the reason I consider this
to be a twist is we'd already had the
villain reveal we were expecting another
one on top of that I say that counts oh
I should probably say before I get too
much further spoilers I guess for
episodes that have already aired but yet
you should know that number 9 Missy is
the master this one I I do like I put it
a little bit lower beak you for a couple
of reasons partly because I know a lot
of people who figured this out well in
advance I wasn't one of them
I didn't figure this out on my own but
I'm also not that great at predicting
twists any like if I've called your
twist in advance you kind of screwed up
because I can spot obvious twists out of
nowhere and this one wasn't obvious
enough for me to grab and I do like any
part of this is in hindsight I love
Missy so much and the way everything
sings in and again a little bit like the
one I just did it's a twist on top of a
twist so it kind of catches you
off-guard cuz you think you've got some
breathing room cuz we've already had the
surprise reveal of the Cybermen which we
didn't know we were dealing with in this
finale and then Missy drops the bomb
short for mistress couldn't keep calling
myself master now could i and you just
the the look on Capaldi's face also
helps really sell this this look of oh
no oh god no that that helps sometimes
it's not just the reveal it's the
reaction of the characters in the scene
number eight I don't know if other
people account this as a twig
I'm gonna count it as a twist though the
narrator for the end of time is revealed
to be Rassilon because the Time Lords
are coming back so at the start of end
of time part 1 we have a narrator and
it's it's a commanding voice but it's
just a narrating voice it's a little
doctor who doesn't deal in narration a
ton and never really from characters we
don't know to some degree but you know
you kind of forget and then the end of
the first part the voice comes back
again and then you see the face it's
like oh my god that's Timothy Dalton and
then you see the Time Lords behind him
holy crap
and especially at that point we didn't
have the full context of what this meant
for the time boys to be coming back
grand we didn't know it was specifically
Rassilon at the point of that reveal but
I got that guy come from the next
episode I really I love this so much and
this actually was also high on my list
when I did greatest cliffhangers I count
this is a double whammy it's a
cliffhanger with a twist and it's a good
twist also Google if hangar number 7 the
reveal of Ruth as the doctor in fugitive
of the Judoon so this is the most recent
one that is on the list because spoiler
the timeless child isn't on here but
this this was pretty well done and this
is not the first time we've had this
sort of reveal in this show but a lot of
it is just that I don't think any of us
were expecting this to get pulled a
second time and then in addition to that
Ruth had just felt so ordinary and she
really did feel like a completely normal
character who just needed a little bit
help and so to see her at her attitude
turn and to see how commanding she
became once she revealed herself to be
the doctor that does a lot to sell that
twist again a lot of times with these
twists it's not just
the idea that has to work it has to be
sold by the script the direction the
acting and this one gets on the list
largely because of the acting because
Joe Martin yeah one more time with her
as the doctor
I just straight up I want it number six
the doctor reversing back through his
time line in the Big Bang now I'm on
record is not really liking the Big Bang
I consider it to be an exercise in tying
up plot threads but it doesn't actually
have an interesting story of its own to
tell I find it very unengaging I don't
really like him but props where props
are due as he's go as he's flashing back
through his own timeline and he gets to
the point from earlier in the season
with flesh and stone' we find out that
something that had been noticed I
remember people noticing this but
largely getting brushed off as a
continuity error because there's a point
when they're in the forest with the
cybernetic trees is the oxygen farm in
the original episode the doctor had lost
his coat and he goes off and you know he
says he's gonna take care of something
and then he comes back and he starts
comforting Amy and he's got his jacket
back on
and a lot of us have written that off as
a continuity error if we caught it at
all but the reason is because this is
the version of him going back through
time and having this comforting moment
and completely recontextualizes that
conversation where now it has a totally
different meaning from what it had
before and it functioned pretty well
previously as well it addled it was a
little bit hmm
but this recontextualized that entire
scene and that that is good that is
clever that is a long game twist at that
that was well executed here we go top
five the reveal of river song's identity
this one again this comes down to
execution
actually the concept and the idea of who
River Song is it doesn't excite me all
that much I don't think the idea that
she turns out to have been melody pond
Amy and Rory's daughter grown up and
reconfigured and manipulated and twisted
around and just having a really screwed
up life that I don't have a self I'm
like okay but it's the way that it's
sold it's the way that it's revealed
it's the music is a huge part of what
sells that it's the performance of Alex
Kingston reserva song it's the
performance of Karen Gillan as Amy and
all of that culminates to a really just
uplifting reveal and this is coming off
a tail end of an episode where it feels
like everything just fell apart and then
you find this on you're like oh well
she's gonna be okay then to whatever
degree you consider everything to be to
be okay and to have had an okay life but
that that a good man goes to war is a
good emotional rollercoaster of an
episode it's up it's down it's up again
and that that's that's a good note to
end that episode on number four flesh
Amy gets dissolved so this was at the
end of the two-parter
the rebel flesh and the almost people so
we had this entire adventure dealing
with these gangers and this goop that
can basically be used to synthesize
people and we've also established that
they can possess the sort of knowledge
and the memories but they kind of need
some degree of link or at least
depending on how the technology is
functioning the way they're designed
they need to have some kind of link to
the original host and we find out the
Amy they've been traveling with for a
little while now isn't really Amy it
acts like Amy
thanks it's Amy
but it's not and they the doctor has to
dissolve her in order to sever the
connection and find the real Amy and how
scared she was how scared Rory was and
how the doctor had to bellow at Rory to
step away from what he had thought was
his wife so the Hat she could be melted
that was harsh and what was cool about
this is because the twist revealed the
twist fed into the overarching story of
that particular series this was series 6
but it it comes off of the two part of
we just did it builds directly off of
everything we've just learned in the
story we just had so it's coming off of
that using that to feed in to the
greater story that's really well done
because I think I can think back to say
series 5 and the episode where Rory died
at the end of the two part of the with
the sigh lorian's and nothing about that
fed into that episode him dying fed into
the overall story of the series but that
scene at the end of that that could have
been tacked on anywhere
it wasn't an organic component of that
two-parter this was so this was this
actually in a way feels like a much
better execution of Rory dying or
appearing to die for real in the series
before I just said it number three for
NOx because the entire lead-in to the
end of time he will knock four times
then the Tenth Doctor David Tennant will
die
now the NOx has been built up primarily
to be the master because he already had
the three beat thing the drums did you
teach you that had already been
established from you know series three
so we've already got that it gets
reiterated as he shows up
like he bangs on this this sort of
cylinder and a junkyard four times the
rhythm of four gets reestablished later
on everything points to the four knocks
being the master and then Wilf
on the other side of this little glass
door stuck in a room that's about to be
irradiated that reveal and all and as
much as I hate tenants little hissy fit
he has after this I do think it's a
really good performance him watching his
face fall when he hears those four
knocks realizing that he didn't escape
his fate and here it comes not to be
delivered by his greatest enemy but to
be delivered by someone he is trying to
protect and someone he cares about
that's good number two the war master
reveal I mentioned when I talked about
Joe Martin's doctor that that wasn't the
first time they pulled this trick this
was and whereas with Joe Martin stalker
wow that still made the list because I
think it's well executed it wasn't as
original this holy rap just the just the
when he turned around and the credit
comes up John Hurt as the doctor of
course we didn't have full context right
away and we had a chunk of time to
speculate one of my earliest videos on
this channel was me speculating about
how the war doctor fit into this stuff
and I was wrong but just the fact that
he even existed was fascinating and a
massive rewriting of so much that we
understood about the doctor and that
it's really hard to hinge a twist
big at the very end of your final
episode of a series because either it's
gonna get everybody super invested super
stoked or it's gonna leave everyone
going what none of this makes sense
anymore I'm out of here
and this manages to just get it just
right I mean like who who did not want
to find out what the hell that meant but
it doesn't quite take the number one
spot I
you could argue it as being number one
and I wouldn't even really debate you on
that but for me the number one twist in
dr. who was from series 3
the episode was utopia and it was the
reveal of the master Derek Jacobi
playing this sweet affable professor
character getting along with the doctor
trying to help humanity a little bit
confused a little bit befuddled
wonderfully sweet and then he opens that
watch the look he does that turn to
camera all the warmth has just drained
out of his presence and the the other
thing is a bit like where we started
with the cult of Skaro part of the
reason that was such a good twist was
that we hadn't established the dogs keep
coming back here Wow
it wouldn't have been the biggest leap
to guess it wasn't a firm pattern yet
that all these old villains were going
to come back and this one was the one
that kind of cemented it because at this
point we'd had the Daleks we got the
Cybermen no got the master like we're
getting the biggies back in but we
didn't know going in that the master
would be back and that he would be
he will be revealed like right under the
doctor's nose he was right there and the
doctor didn't know and even if you don't
know who the master is which honestly
first time I saw this I didn't really I
had gotten into the show but I didn't
watch a lot of classic before getting
into this stuff and certainly not at
that point in the show and I knew who
the master was because I'd like looked
up some stuff about classic so I heard
the name and I knew what that meant but
I didn't have any investment in the
master and that's thing still hit me
like a freight train and if you know who
the master is I think it hits you all
the harder and I think that's the best
twist and Doctor Who what do you think
is the best twist whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about how much you want to
bet people are gonna think of one that I
completely forgot about I'm gonna go oh
god I was a [ __ ] wouldn't that be a
twist but there's also the usual stuff
to do like subscribe pass this around
share this video I have a patreon as I
mentioned at the front end link below
all that stuff but you don't have to do
any of it end of the day folks I mean
you're the council just run the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]